[Music]
i want to start with this sell-off we're
seeing in stocks actually last last week
really rough start to 2022 and we're
seeing big tech get beaten up really the
most with the nasdaq now
formally in a correction are you using
this as a buying opportunity and if so
what are you loading up on right now
i am actually i mean first of all let's
talk about the volatility in tech
tech stocks are historically volatile
they trade at high pes many of them
trade based on growth metrics not
necessarily earnings and that gives them
very very high multiples and so
generally speaking they have volatility
but the way i look at it in corrections
like this
is has has anything fundamentally
changed in their business models i mean
are you going to use zoom less there's a
speculative name are you going to use
google less or is it going to continue
to grow is microsoft still going to be
an enterprise platform the answer is yes
to all these questions and so when you
get volatility
generally speaking in my world i take
advantage of it because i have to deploy
capital all the time and i have to
decide where am i going to put it i like
growth and i understand it's going to be
volatile and days like this i remind
myself i've seen this movie before go
back 17 years on amazon which i've owned
for almost that entire stretch we had 30
40 50 corrections each year
and yet look where you end up today and
so i look at it and say to myself let's
learn from the past apply that to the
future take advantage of volatility the
economy is strong
the use case for technology it gets more
important enterprise every day in every
part of the globe that's the investment
thesis
so kevin we know the new year brings a
lot of headwinds but there are also lots
of opportunities so what is the biggest
opportunity for investors as you see it
in the new year
well the one that
i really found interesting uh over the
last 24 months
has been um crypto and and blockchain
technologies and tokens and nfts
you know you have to make a binary
decision about this stuff and this is
very difficult for many institutions i
talk to them every day because i'm in
the indexing business and many of them
have not even started their journey into
cryptocurrencies but
the reason you should think about it is
this this is this is how i wrap my head
around it and i think it helps investors
to think this way
if you invest in microsoft and google
and amazon and so many of these other
platforms what is the core you're
investing and it's basically
software
google software well bitcoin is not a
coin it's actually software the
blockchain is software ethereum is
software hbar is software polygon and
software
so the real decision is if you're
willing to invest in software because
it's a productivity tool
as an equity such as google
why wouldn't you invest in software such
as ethereum because it provides a
service
particularly in payment systems that is
being used globally and that's sort of
my investment thesis and then the
question is which coins which tokens
which blockchains and for that i apply
the same rules of diversification i
apply to my stocks and bonds no more
than five percent any one position
no more than 20 in the whole sector so
i'm not anywhere near 20 in crypto i've
just gone over 10.7
in in the in our operating company but i
have a plethora of positions and i'm
going to make this decision there that
this is even more volatile than
technology equities and it certainly is
bitcoin's having one of its worst starts
ever but you have to get used to it just
like you had to get used to amazon where
it would have these 30 to 50 corrections
same thing with bitcoin
so are you using crypto sort of as a way
to hedge or diversify from other assets
like uh
like real estate for instance are you
using a sort of instead of the way we
would traditionally use gold as a hedge
that's an excellent question and the
answer is yes and there's a direct tie
in real estate here was my dilemma last
year
i sold a lot of our commercial real
estate in our portfolio turned into cash
called my cash desk said what are we
getting for this cash because i haven't
got any ideas to deploy it yet i need
some time
because i like to put cash back in the
market slowly take advantage of
corrective days like this et cetera
and they said we can get 20 basis points
20 basis points and i said wait a second
inflation's over 6
that means i'm being taxed at 5.8
percent on holding cash and that was
when i started my exploration into
crypto and it took me to two
platforms that um
i use today ftx for where i hold a lot
of my decentralized and i have to
disclose on a paid spokesperson and an
investor in ftx and use their platform
and circle where i use usdc where i
stake stable coins and get somewhere
between four and six percent interest
that was my first exposure and let me
tell you something you know
it took me six months to get my own
compliance department and my own
external auditor to agree
to sign my statements that's how
difficult this is going to be but as the
adult and that is in fact the the
tremendous potential of crypto
if we make it regulated if we get
institutions into it and
find a way for them to be compliant
there's trillions of dollars going to
come into this space because it has a
pragmatic use
now i'm at least keeping pace with
inflation on my circle stake and i've
got a wide range of holdings in my ftx
account and it's completely compliant
with my external auditors
and my internal compliance department it
took a long time to set up other
institutions are going through the same
birthing pains
yeah we'll see if 2022 brings some
clearer regulation in that space kevin
but i'm curious if you've bought any of
those non-fungible tokens those nfts how
much of the portfolio is dedicated to
those
no i i i don't have a lot of nfts yet
but i will tell you i actually believe
that the potential for the nft market is
actually larger than bitcoin and i'll
tell you why
the idea and let's take a a physical
asset the one i like to use as an
example is watches i'm a huge watch
collector i have a massive collection of
watches one of the biggest challenges i
have is inventory management insurance
management and then of course
authentication when people offer me
vintage watches i have to go through a
very arduous authentication process to
know if it's fake or not there's so many
fake watches in the market
nfts could solve all of those problems
so
in the in the case a use case for the
multi-billion dollar watch industry
because the actual trading of
second-hand watches is 10 times the size
of the original watch market each year
because there's billions of dollars
worth of you know very desirable watches
that trade all around the world if i
could turn all of my watches into nfts
and
that way i could let my insurance
company know look these are the 10
they're out of the vault this week bid
me on insurance just for these 10.
here's where they're located here's why
i want them in short and all the rest
i'd self-insure because they're in a
bank vault in some city somewhere
authentication every time i sell that
watch the scan of its dial which is down
at the micron level attached to the nft
would authenticate it you can rescan it
and prove that was the original watch so
for that kind of thing same with real
estate same with fine jewelry same with
pins same with cars all of this
is going to move on to the chain and so
the best way to invest in it from my
point of view is make take positions
like i invested in immuno.com they own
nft.com they're building a curation
platform for nfts
everywhere and so that's an equity that
i own i own wonderfuy.com which is just
bought the largest exchange
in canada they own they have 375 000
accounts in a jurisdiction
that really is
progressive in crypto the the swiss the
canadians the uae government some of
these some of these places are now
becoming a little bit more progressive
and you have to invest in those
geographies if you want exposure so
there's a lot going on
but it it certainly takes a fair you
know point a lot a lot of time in my day
just tracking all this stuff i'd say i
spent 40 percent of my investment day
tracking cryptocurrencies now
um you know we actually had the ceo of
wonder five ben sammer on uh recently to
talk about that deal so all right we we
understand it we get it you're liking
the nfts you're liking the crypto what
else do you like talk to us about other
sectors where you really see opportunity
this year
well you know i've i've always had a
five percent weighting in gold people
don't talk about gold any much very much
anymore because cryptos become the gold
du jour the digital gold so to speak but
it's still actually i think an asset you
want to have
in a rising rate environment and i think
diversification now towards stronger
balance sheets
is going to be very important i i think
if if you
you think about a portfolio you're
managing an equity portfolio
for growth you're going to have vault
there's no question so if you're going
to put 20 into technology you're going
to see price swings like we're having
today but if you want stability go
through the s p 500 and find the balance
sheets that are the strongest that
actually are growing free cash flows
distributing portions of those profits
through dividends so my theory for 2022
is this we're not going to get another
20 plus percent return in the equity
markets
it's going to be more muted more like
eight or nine percent earnings growth i
think will be around eight percent on
the s p 500 plus add another 100 basis
points for dividend distributions you're
gonna make eight or nine percent this
year you're going to go through a lot of
volatility but that's still way better
than what how you're being treated in
the fixed income market plus think about
the risk you've got if you buy long
duration bonds right now you're going to
get killed if rates continue to go up
and the yields right now on aaa or
triple b and above
corporate credits are not that
attractive they're still sort of three
three and a half percent which doesn't
even beat inflation so i think right now
it's it's
focusing on higher quality names for
example i don't own the airlines take
united for example i always use this use
case they started the pandemic with 7
billion in debt now they're way over 20.
why would you want to own that balance
sheet why there's no reason to do that
there's so many other companies that
don't have that upside down balance
sheet situation today and those are the
ones you have to look at you've got to
groom through the s p
and pick your positions and then for
growth you stick with technology
hey mr wonderful here and you know where
i am this is one of the biggest boat
regattas in the world it's the head of
the charles in cambridge massachusetts
now it's a really big weekend and people
come from all around the world to watch
and be participants in it over 9 000
athletes here some of them olympians
some of them like rob right here who's
part of this whole organization and a
rower how did it get started because i
know it's been around forever but it
started in 1965
it was a small event and as it's grown
over the years it's now over uh two and
a half days long uh there are hundreds
of competitors uh you know different
clubs participating and all the
competitors across the days
[Music]
all right you can't have an event like
this without huge sponsorship there's
hundreds of thousands of people
attending this that would give you some
idea why sponsors would want to sponsor
it of course but it's only a two to
three day event at best so let's ask jim
here who's a major sponsor
why what's the reason you do this so the
reason we chose the head of the
charleston sponsor this year is it
really embodies crew in general embodies
you know the entrepreneurial spirit that
the owners of the company really always
enjoy talking about they've started this
themselves we're 23 years old and we're
thrilled to jump into this for the first
year we're in a very competitive markets
clothing right absolutely okay and what
is it what's the association with
growing is there a fit so for the
association of rowing is we're not going
to be the technical brand but we're
going to be the brand that shows up to
the event you feel comfortable in you
feel great in and you're proud to be
along with we've got friends and family
supporting these rowers and rowers
themselves are just thrilled to be out
out and about again after cobit we've
got 11 000 competitors we've got 800
clubs we've got roughly 400 000 people
walking through here and the excitement
is absolutely helpful so this is a
pop-up boutique this is a pop-up
boutique this was a one day build it all
get rolling make sure the registers go
and we're thrilled this was canceled
last year for covert for good reason
this year you know the team here did an
amazing job at making it coveted
friendly yet also service whether the
weather came at us which thankfully it
didn't we had tents available if need be
tell me about your business how much of
is it retail and how much is direct to
consumer online after the pandemic so we
really leaned into the
direct-to-consumer online during covet
obviously but that being said we kept
our retail doors going the entire time
we've taken this as an opportunity to
really connect with our customer and
find out what they're looking for and
moving forward how we can better serve
them whether that's doing things spur of
the moment and on demand which we've
really become experts at or
delivering some of the classics that we
have so you know a vest over here or a
shepherd on one of the mannequins behind
me is something that we've been behind
for 20 years what they encourage is
entrepreneurship so everybody on our
team is going to go home and say how can
we make this better for next year how
can we come up with new fun exciting
ways to do it and the encouragement from
two brothers who own the company is just
absolutely something that everybody in
the tent behind me um sounds empowering
so let's talk about the daily regimen
you talked about getting up and doing it
before you went to work yeah what time
do you get up in the morning uh well
obviously this is the thing you got to
you got to get to you got to get like
six hours right so
you know if you're getting up at um if
you're getting up at 4 30 5 o'clock you
gotta you got to get to bed um you know
10 o'clock 10 30 something like that and
if the sleep will kill you that's that's
that's the one thing that you can't do
without yeah so you're you're going to
bed around 10 you're getting up at 4 30.
yeah and then when are you on the water
usually on the water here about 5 30.
there's no light ah there is in the
summer in the summer it's really nice
the city's really quiet you got the
whole place to yourself
um you know in the fall the schools are
back and you know the days start getting
shorter so it gets a little crazy here
in september once you've learned how to
row in the dark you can do it because
you just follow the shoreline and um you
can do it you have to have bow lights
and you know safety equipment and all
that kind of stuff but they're they're
people that row and i'm not one of those
but there are people that just row in
the dark
[Music]
and one of the things that sometimes
people don't realize is just how
technical a sport it is so it certainly
involves a lot of strength but getting
eight people working together in unison
to maximize the speed of the boat
really involves in a huge amount of
technique as well as strength so that's
why they practice practice practice they
know each other this crew's been
together right that's correct who's the
oldest rower i mean
there must be somebody there are people
in their 80s who are still competing in
the head of the charles
you chuckle you can do it
and it's it's never it's never too late
to start kevin really yeah i'm going to
get you out there we're going to get you
i got to get out there no questions
about it if you like that video wait you
see my next one don't forget to click
right over here and subscribe